hey you guys time once again for another
movie retrospective and again just like
last week um doing having to do this by
myself just because the day that it was
supposed to be recorded like tom uh
unexpectedly had to go do something else
so i said well you just go ahead because
i gotta get this uh kicked out i gotta
get it edited i gotta get it put up uh
so i'll just talk about this by myself
and it'll completely be fine
so the movie that we're talking about
this week is a [ __ ] classic going all
the way back to the 1950s and talking
about some [ __ ] vincent price
goodness
this is house of wax
now
i had seen this movie a very long time
ago
um i'll talk a little bit about i don't
know if i necessarily want to talk too
much about the 2005 remake which was
okay but i felt like you know it had
some good gore and stuff like that um
but it wasn't really a remake of house
of wax it almost kind of seemed more
like
a remake of sort of house of wax sort of
wax work sort of tourist trap i kind of
felt like it was more like a slasher
movie but it was like a pretty decent
flick but it's not really the same story
now the 1953 vincent price house of wax
i'm not sure if a lot of people know
this is itself a remake uh it was
actually a remake of a 1933 film called
mystery of the wax museum
which was like a thriller
and interestingly um other than a couple
uh different things plot like a couple
characters that were taken out uh it's
very very similar to that earlier film
like uh you know the plot is very very
similar even some of the gags are
repeated if you've seen the 1953 house
of wax uh there's a gag in there with
like two of the morgue attendants and
they go in there and one of the bodies
like sits up yeah it's like the bodies
sit up sometimes the gases or whatever
it is like the preparation so that's gag
is even in the original movie as i said
there's a couple changes um the 1933 one
was actually pre-haze code so they
actually got away with a couple of
things in there that they wouldn't have
got away with in the 50s one for example
uh one of the guys like one of the
uh proprietor the wax museum like the
villain
one of his henchmen is a criminal and
like the cops bring him in and in the
original movie they actually get him to
talk by like he's a heroine addict and
he's you know he's a junkie and he's
like jonesing so they're like hey we'll
give you some heroin if you like tell us
what we want to know and like dangling
in front of him so they couldn't do that
in the 50s one because of the haze code
so they actually made him an alcoholic
but the scene is otherwise the same
which i thought was very interesting
hayes code pre-haze code and uh haze
code is very very interesting to me
so house of wax the 1953 one um vincent
price had been
in several movies prior to this
obviously i believe he started his
acting career in the late 1930s i want
to say
um although normally like before that i
kind of felt like he'd played more kind
of like sympathetic characters more more
leading men but you know like
good guys you know what i'm saying
this movie
was sort of the first one that he was in
where he ended up playing a villain and
it made such a big impact
that this essentially like
uh scripted pretty much the rest of his
career of him playing you know these
kind of like mad scientist characters
playing villainous type of characters uh
you know the edgar allen poe movies that
would come out later on the roger corman
ones this was kind of ground zero for
that i guess if you want to call it that
this is the first movie where he
actually played a straight up villain
and obviously made a really big impact
and that's kind of like the jobs he got
going forward
now this was directed by andrei de toth
who
is a hungarian filmmaker and had made a
lot of movies in hungary i believe he
made a couple more movies for major
studios later on one of which was a
crime wave he made kind of a lot of uh
noir and like crime kind of movies
gangster type stuff later on and also i
think in the late 70s i think he was
even like a second unit director on like
superman the richard donner one and
stuff like that so he had a very very uh
long career
this was also uh interestingly the first
color
3d movie put out by a major american
studio which was columbia pictures it
wasn't the first 3d movie because i
think they had released a 3d black and
white one
uh not even the same year or the year
before and there had actually been an
independent color 3d movie i think it
was called buana 3d or something and it
was like this massive massive hit which
is what gave colombia the idea to put
this one in 3d did this need to be in 3d
probably not but
honestly i didn't get to see it because
i watched this on shutter you can watch
it on shutter you can watch it on amazon
prime if you have amazon prime i believe
you can watch it on there for free but
it's on shutter as well shutter also has
the 2005 house of wax so if you want to
like compare the two they're very very
different uh but you know if that's kind
of what you're into you can totally do
that but there is actually i'm pretty
sure it's available in the u.s but there
is a blu-ray that actually has the 1953
house of wax the 1933 mystery the wax
museum and it also has uh the 3d version
you can watch the 3d version of the
1950s like on your home tv i guess if
you're like set up for that now i
watched a review
one of my favorite horror channels is
grumpy andrew he actually had the 3d one
and he said that watching it in 3d at
home was like an amazing experience as i
said there are a couple of gags in this
that you know that they put in just for
the 3d like coming at you type stuff but
he's like it's not even that it's like
just the depth of field of like the set
dressing like the set design like the
wax museum it's like it just looks
really really awesome and he was talking
about uh there's like a chase scene
where you know the villain is chasing
this woman through this these creepy
streets that looks like london but i
guess it's supposed to be new york and
he's like and it just looks so cool like
the depth of field like looks really
great so he's like the 3d back then uh
at least in this context looked even
better than like some of the 3d [ __ ] you
see nowadays so he's like i'm not really
sure why now interestingly if you watch
this still like nowadays and they have
this on shutter as well like halfway
it's not a long movie i think it's only
88 minutes halfway through the movie
there's like a an intermission card uh
even though you know it's very short and
that was because what they used to do i
guess the movies you know please correct
me if i'm wrong but i guess movies used
to be on two reels
and you'd load up real one and reel two
in your two uh projectors like in the
theater and then you could just switch
from one to the other without anybody
being the wiser however a 3d movie they
had to actually have the same film
running in both or you know a version of
the same film running simultaneously in
both the projectors so when they had the
intermission that's when they had to
stop and take both of them out and then
put new ones in so they'd run
simultaneously so you could get the 3d
effect because that's how they used to
do it
so uh so this movie
uh basically the story behind it vincent
price plays an artist
named professor henry jarrod
now at the beginning of the uh movie
this is actually set i couldn't tell
what year it was i knew it was like
somewhere around the early like 20th
century like turn of the century i
believe it's supposed to be set around
1902 uh so it's not actually set at the
time that the movie came out even though
i believe the 1933 one mystery of the
wax museum i think that was set in the
30s but this one is actually set in 1902
and actually that's it's quite cool it's
i actually really like that kind of
dynamic to it and it almost has some of
the um
like chase sequences uh you know at you
know when it gets into kind of the good
part of the movie with vincent price
being the villain it almost has like a
little bit of a jack the ripper kind of
vibe to it and i'm pretty sure that was
intentional because i said i believe
it's supposed to have been taking place
in new york at least the way they're
talking about like the streets and the
locations and stuff uh but the the way
that they built the sets i mean it looks
like it was all done on a set but
there's nothing wrong with that
uh it was all done on a set but it looks
like very much like the old cobblestone
streets of
of london like in the late 1800s when
jack the ripper was like lurking around
so i do definitely feel like they were
trying to go for that kind of vibe which
i quite enjoyed
so uh henry jarrod vincent price's
character is an artist and he is a wax a
wax sculpture
sculptor rather
and he has
a small wax museum
and basically his whole thing is he's
very much into beauty
so he has all these gorgeous
figures of you know marie antoinette
which is kind of like his uh magnum opus
i guess it's this gorgeous i mean i will
say too like the wax figures in this
whoever did them uh are
pretty amazing i mean they look really
really good like all the costuming and
the face and everything they look really
great so uh so yeah he has marie
antoinette's joan of arc
you know he has
lincoln and john wilkes booth and all
this other stuff but he's very into
making them beautiful
now he has a business partner named
burke
and burke is kind of like the money guy
he's not really like you know he's not
an artistic type of person so he's
basically like well look i invested in
this little museum um you know they they
get some traffic but not a lot and he's
like you know what we need to do and i
keep telling you this is we need to put
a [ __ ] chamber of horrors in here you
need to put like grizzly [ __ ] people
love that
and vincent price i keep calling him
that i'm just gonna call him that that's
what it's fun
i know it is i know his character has a
day but i was gonna he's [ __ ] been to
price right you just gotta call him
vincent price so vincent price is like
yeah i don't want to do that i want to
cater to that kind of people that's like
lowest common denom denominator kind of
[ __ ] my whole thing is like about beauty
and you know i'm just not willing to do
that
and he's like but but he's cool about it
though he's like look if you don't want
to be involved he's like i have this
other guy who is an investor and he
seems like he's kind of more on my
wavelength and he's coming over tonight
to have a look around and maybe he'll
buy you out uh you know so burke's like
okay that's cool
so this uh this investor comes over and
he seems like very very interesting he's
like wow this your stuff is amazing and
it's like yeah i'd really be interested
in like going into this he's like but i
can't do it right now because i have to
go fund this you know expedition in
egypt or whatever but i'll be back in
three months and you know then we'll
talk business and i'll we'll see we can
do i can buy your other partner out
so you know vincent price very happy
about this he's like oh good i got like
a new investor but burke is not having
it he wants some [ __ ] money like
right now
and he's mad that vincent price won't
uh you know concede to his demands of
like putting some more macabre stuff
into the wax museum so he decides he's
gonna uh as tom would say cross the
insurance wires and he's like you know
what i'm just gonna burn this [ __ ]
place down and uh you know get the
insurance money so he proceeds to do
pretty much exactly that so the first
like part of the movie basically like
after the tour with the other investors
and stuff is just this dude like going
around setting all the wax figures on
fire and he's and him and vincent price
are like tussling because obviously
vincent price like this is my life's
work you're ruining it and you know so
they're fighting and everything but he
like knocks vincent price out burke does
and uh then he's like well [ __ ] i'll
just set you on fire too more money for
me so that's basically what he does he
just burns the [ __ ] place to the
ground and everybody thinks i mean you
know this isn't what happens but
everybody thinks that vincent price was
also killed in the fire
now we jump forward a little while like
not i don't i don't know if they say
like how long it wasn't that long
but it was long enough for i guess for
the insurance to come in and for burke
to get all the insurance money i think
it was 25 000 which you know was nothing
to sneeze at back in 1953.
now what he's thinking about doing with
this money he has this girlfriend who i
guess he's kind of like stringing along
or whatever now i loved this
the girlfriend at the beginning is this
kind of
uh she's this she has these beautiful
like blonde curls and she's very like
giggly and very feminine and she seems
like she's looking for a sugar daddy
type thing this woman
is played by
carolyn jones uh who is best known to
millions of people everywhere nowadays
as the beautiful morticia adams from the
original adams family show she's
recognizable in this but it's crazy to
see her because this was probably like
10 years before i think it was about 10
years before the adams family show
was on so this might have been her first
movie or kind of her first major role
she's not in it a lot because she gets
spoiler alert because she gets murdered
like pretty early on in the movie but um
but yeah she's in like several scenes at
the beginning and her face is like
immediately recognizable but it's just
so funny to see her with these little
blonde curls and like wearing pink like
with all the little pink corset and her
like giggling and being all girly and
stuff and i was just like it was just
that amused the [ __ ] out of me but uh
and her voice like sounded cuz i don't
know i guess she was putting on like a
more femi kind of voice so she's trying
to get burke you know burke's like oh
you know my poor partner he he died in
that fire what a shame boohoo and he's
like yeah i have all this money and
she's like oh that means you can marry
me now and he's just like oh look at the
time you know he's that kind of dude
now uh what ends up happening with that
is that burke goes back to his office or
whatever and is uh getting his
ill-gotten gains out of his safe and
then this creepy ass
dude who is who has this really [ __ ]
up looking face and he has like this
black cloak and a big black hat and he
walks all [ __ ] up like all gimpy and
whatever and he comes in there and
essentially like kills burke and makes
it look like a suicide like he he kind
of like knocks him out and then like
drags him out into the hall and like
hangs him in the elevator so it makes it
look like he killed himself not too long
after this uh carolyn jones's character
whose name is kathy gray she's gonna go
out on a date because she's like oh bert
got killed whatever she's like looking
for a new dude now who's gonna you know
marry her and
give her a taste of the high life or
whatever so she's going out with a new
guy
and she lives in kind of like a boarding
house and her roommate is a woman named
sue or sue allen so she goes out on a
date and then they say that the girls
are kind of having problems like sue is
kind of unemployed and she's looking for
a job she goes to a job interview she
doesn't get the job and so like the you
know the person that runs the boarding
house is like look [ __ ] you gotta
give us some money or we're gonna kick
your ass out and she's just like oh you
know no please you know maybe maybe
kathy when she goes on the date maybe
she'll be able to like talk some money
out of this new dude that she's seeing
or whatever uh however that is not how
[ __ ] goes down it turns out that kathy
gray uh was murdered by the same [ __ ]
up looking dude who hanged burke you
know the the business partner now
i don't think i mean this is an old ass
movie it's 1953 and it's a remake from
an even older ass movie for but ic33 so
i don't think it's too much of a spoiler
to say and even if you're watching it
today um you know because this movie is
what like almost 70 years old and so i
you know obviously you're gonna know
that this [ __ ] up looking dude that's
running around is obviously vincent
price because you know he was in a fire
and whatnot but
they kind of try to throw you for a loop
a little bit because what ends up
happening is that you see vincent price
later and he's looking all suave and
normal now he's in a wheelchair and he
can't really walk all that well and his
hands are all [ __ ] up so he's but he's
like okay well i got all these new
investors i'm gonna open uh another wax
museum another wax works um and i guess
i'm gonna give the public what they want
they want all this horror [ __ ] well i'm
gonna put all this horror [ __ ] in there
so he basically opens up this big huge
place like on i think it's on broadway
or something and it has like all this
real gruesome [ __ ] like it has like
[ __ ] charlotte corday like stabbing
mara it has uh you know joan of arc
being burned alive it has uh amber lynn
getting beheaded it has all that kind of
fun [ __ ] in there and uh it's
interesting too
because
this is something that i kind of noticed
when i was watching the movie i was like
the theme of this movie being sort of
like i don't know if it's like the theme
but it's kind of a through line that
runs throughout the plot is like art
versus commerce right so vincent price
being an artist at the beginning and
he's like i won't lower myself to do all
this horror stuff because i don't want
to do that i'm more into beauty i want
people to come here and see beautiful
things rather than seeing grotesque
things so he doesn't want to do that so
but after he um you know is in the fire
and is disfigured and his hands are all
[ __ ] up and he can't work anymore like
so now he has to employ other sculptors
like hunchmen to help him out because
he's not able to do it um you know he's
kind of
you know not surprisingly become
hardened so it's interesting that you
know he's nice guy a nice guy and then
you know it kind of leads up to that and
then you have the intermission and then
after the intermission it's almost like
the movie
kind of goes into because he's like oh
well i'm going to be like this [ __ ]
carnival barker type of person which he
didn't want to be before because that's
apparently what the public wants because
now he's all [ __ ] cynical and
everything so after the intermission the
first thing you see is like this
carnival barker type dude outside of the
new house of wax with one of those
paddle ball things actually he's got two
of them and it's like 3d like commodity
coming at you so it's funny how after
the intermission like after he has come
back with this new
more public friendly i guess or more
grotesque house of wax then it's almost
like the 3d and it gets purposely more
uh vaudevillian i guess or like more in
your face so so you have like this big
long scene of this guy with these paddle
balls just like doing them like right in
your face and he even makes jokes about
like he's gonna knock somebody's popcorn
out of their hand you know what i mean
so it's like you know like coming at you
like if you're sitting in the theater
when you were seeing this and then
there's a scene later where just for no
reason at all
like one like uh the guy like sue's
boyfriend like takes her to this can-can
show so there's like a really long
sequence of all these can can girls like
kicking their legs like toward the
camera and like sticking their roughly
butts in the camera and stuff like that
so it's just like really really funny
that they kind of did that and like i
said the movie it didn't really
necessarily have to be in 3d and that
really the paddle ball scene and the can
can girls scene are the only scenes that
are
like very very deliberately hey there's
stuff coming at you because it's 3d you
know what i mean um the rest of it
didn't really have to be in 3d but as i
mentioned i didn't never got to see it
in 3d but people that i you know that i
watched on youtube that have seen it in
3d said it actually looked really
beautiful not just because stuff was
coming in your face but just because the
depth of field and you could see like
all the um you know the wax figures and
the way the set design and everything
like that because the set design
production design in this is really
really nice and i'm pretty sure like i
said it was all constructed on sound
stages like the entire wax museum and
like the thing in the back like the
factory where they where he makes the
figures and all that
so uh so yeah so he opens this brand new
wax museum with all this horrific [ __ ]
in it and obviously the public's like
eating it up
now sue um who is pretty traumatized
still by the death of her best friend
kathy uh aka morticia and uh so she's
you know and she's the one that found
the body and she also saw the dude you
know she saw the deformed guy like
running around in the in the street and
he chased her so obviously he was going
to kill her as well but she was able to
evade him so she goes to this wax museum
like opening because her boyfriend is
also a sculptor and he's kind of looking
to you know get in there and like help
the dude out with his with his work
because as i said vincent price's
character his hands are all we're all
[ __ ] up in the fire and he can't
sculpt anymore so he needs you know
helpers to help him out doing it
so uh so she goes there and one of the
things that she notices is that the
figure of joan of arc that is in this
house of wax
looks suspiciously like her best friend
kathy gray and so she's kind of up there
looking like man that is really um
that that's unsettling so she's kind of
like really upset about it and of course
like all the dudes around her like oh
you're silly just like yeah it kind of
looks like her but it's no big or
whatever and uh you know why why are you
getting all hysterical and
that kind of thing like no one really
believes her obviously uh so vincent
price like rolls over in his wheelchair
and he says to her it's like oh i'm
really sorry i upset you it's like um
you know yeah yes it does look like her
but that's because i saw her picture in
the paper like after she got murdered
and i thought she had a beautiful face
and so i used her face like as a model
now sue is kind of like yeah i guess
that makes sense but then she starts
thinking about like other little details
and she's like yeah but how would he
have known about like her she had like
one ear pierced and how would she even
know like all these other little details
about her that she can see uh you know
in the wax figure she's like just from a
picture in the newspaper so she's really
not buying it but
you know she tries to kind of like
report things to the cops and everything
like that but again they're just like
you're just a woman you don't you don't
know how anything works you know what i
mean it's that kind of thing like
everybody's i think there's even a line
in there where
you know she's because she's really not
letting it go this is her best friend
her best friend got murdered she found
the girl and the murderer chased her
through the streets as well
so she's not letting this go
understandably but every time she goes
to the cops everyone's just kind of like
uh you know that's just like a skirt to
make up something i think that's even a
line in there it's just like a skirt
like to make up something crazy like
that or whatever
uh so again this is not really a spoiler
because
anybody that has seen any horror movie
in the last 60 70 years will know that
the reason that a lot of these wax
figures look so much like real people is
because they are indeed real people and
honestly like even before they do the
scene where sue goes into the wax museum
and sees the joan of arc that looks just
like her friend
then uh there's a scene where the where
the like [ __ ] up looking dude goes
into the morgue and steals her body so
you obviously know that there's
something nefarious going on so there's
grave robbing there's all this other
kind of stuff another fun fact he
actually um vincent price's character
actually has two
helpers one of whom
is played he's uh named igor because of
course he is and he's a deaf mute
and he's actually played by
charles bronson
which uh i think he was credited under
his real name which i think is charles
bachinski um but it's definitely him
it's weird because when you see him at
first you're kind of like i was kind of
like that's charles bronson isn't it and
then i was like oh maybe not but then
like a couple of angles i'm like oh
that's definitely charles bronson and
then when i looked it up later it
definitely is charles bronson so i don't
know if this was his first movie but he
doesn't have any speaking lines
obviously because he's mute but he's
definitely in this and he's one of he's
kind of like the muscle you know what i
mean
so as i said it will surprise no one to
know that what's been going on is that
vincent price the normal looking nice
vincent price who's in the wheelchair
and only his hands are kind of [ __ ] up
is obviously the same person as the
[ __ ] up looking dude uh because
there's a very very famous scene at the
end where sue is you know he's trying to
get sue because he's like oh your face
looks just like what i wanted for my new
marie antoinette which like i said his
old marie antoinette which got burned
alive that was burned alive she's a wax
figure but got burned up like in the
beginning of the movie that was like his
his great life's work and so he's been
looking for another model uh to make
another one and it's gonna be like even
better than before so sue obviously has
this perfect marie antoinette face so
he's just like itching to get his little
uh his little like [ __ ] up hands on
her so he can you know throw her in the
in the vat of wax cover up with wax and
like do all this other stuff so uh so
that's essentially what happens like so
there's kind of like a
uh you know everybody not believing her
even though she's pretty sure that some
of these wax figures are real bodies i
think it's
i think it's basically led to believe
that they all are because he says well i
can't sculpt anymore um but his cover
story is oh my helpers
help me by sculpting them i just tell
them what to do but what he's actually
doing is taking bodies of people he
doesn't like and covering them with wax
so they're like super super lifelike
because it's easier for him he's built
like this whole elaborate thing with
like i said a big
[ __ ] thing of boiling wax and all
this other kind of [ __ ] and uh so he's
just like pouring wax over them and just
kind of like dressing them up and
whatnot and then displaying them in you
know in in the wax museum and no one
being the wiser so that's essentially
what the what the movie is this is i
mean for the 1950s
it's weird because i kind of feel like a
lot of especially in the united states a
lot of movies that came out of the 50s
were more kind of like sci-fi you know
like you know it was a big bug you know
alien type movies this one is almost
kind of like a throwback um which i
guess isn't surprising since it was a
remake of a movie from the 30s so it's
much more like a gothic uh thriller type
of thing and i think like even at the
time
some of the uh reviews of it were kind
of like not that great because they're
saying oh this is like such a
you know it's like it's such an old type
movie like they don't you know we don't
make this kind of stuff anymore which is
funny to think about like from the 1950s
but yeah a lot of people weren't really
into it but over the ensuing decades i
think this is really
um kind of risen through the ranks to
become
i mean a horror classic it's just it's a
beautiful looking movie like it's shot
beautifully vincent price is just so
great in it um he's actually compared to
some of his later villain roles he's
pretty subdued because like i said i'm
pretty sure this was his first
villainous type of role um and he's
essentially playing two
carrick i mean it's the same guy but
he's essentially playing two characters
because you know his [ __ ] up looking
face that's his real face because he
actually was uh disfigured in the fire
but he's essentially built a wax face
that looked like his old face and it's
good enough that nobody sees you know
because like i said there's that famous
scene where sue is pounding on it and
all the wax falls off and like all the
[ __ ] up and the makeup on the you know
on his disfigured that looks like really
really good one of the stories that i've
heard i don't know if this is true or
not but uh one of the stories that i've
heard is that when he was in that makeup
um everybody else that was working on
the movie like he wasn't allowed to like
come into the cafeteria or the
commissary or whatever like to eat with
the rest of them because everybody was
like so grossed out by what the makeup
looked like and it was like so upsetting
that it was like making them like turn
in their stomach or whatever like i said
i don't know like maybe people are more
sensitive effect that or whatever it's
just makeup but the makeup in this still
looks really really good you have to
think this is like 19 [ __ ] 53 man
they didn't have no cgi no nothing and
it looks really really good like he
looks pretty grody and uh you know it
just looks like a really really good
makeup job now i will say that the
remake as i said that they made in 2005
that famously had paris hilton getting
killed with a spike through her head or
whatever is a pretty okay movie and i
like that they had um there's a lot of
gore in it and most of it's practical uh
the cgi in it isn't good but um you know
there's not a lot of cgi but they
introduced a lot of elements that
weren't in this one um in a sense like i
said they made it more like a teen
slasher type of thing um they made the
killers like twins instead of just one
guy who was covering up his face um and
they just kind of introduced some other
elements that weren't there like i said
the remake it's still kind of a remake
of house of wax but it reminded me a lot
more of tourist trap or maybe wax work
um more than house of wax but it's still
like a pretty decent movie for that era
i'm not a big fan of all the kind of
remakes that they made like all the
slasher remakes that they made in the
early 2000s um just i don't know but
this is that was actually kind of one of
the better ones but honestly if you're
gonna watch house of wax the 1933 one is
actually totally worth watching too um
it's it's pretty decent but i mean you
can't beat
[ __ ] the beautiful technicolor
3d
vincent price uh making these beautiful
wax figures and it just looks so good
and it really really holds up to this
day still and you know so honestly um
you can't really go wrong with vincent
price every single thing i've seen him
in uh he was amazing he's just he was
just an amazing dude and he's anything
that he's in is worth watching and this
is definitely one of his best uh movies
and i know there's like that's like a
long list but this is definitely one of
his best movies i love [ __ ] about wax
museums i love all that kind of stuff as
i said you know nowadays nothing in it's
going to surprise you like back then
maybe it was like a big shock that oh
the deformed guy and the vincent price
in the wheelchair oh my god it's the
same dude but you know and or oh my god
those he's really like using bodies to
make wax figures out of nowadays that's
not going to surprise anybody but you
know it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
that you know you see the twist coming
you know what's happening it's just you
know it's it's nice enough to just like
sit back and enjoy like the beautiful
set design and like the acting and
everything it's just a fun
movie and if you can watch it in 3d
because like i said it's i watched it on
shutter so obviously you can't watch it
on 3d on there but i believe that there
is a blu-ray that you that is 3d and the
3d on it is apparently looks really good
so if you can get hold of that
or if you've seen it in 3d let me know
what it looks like because i've heard it
looks like really really good and i'd be
interested to see it in all its 3d glory
it's good without that but now i'm kind
of like interested to to see it but yeah
i mean house of wax it's a [ __ ]
classic if you haven't seen it
definitely go to shutter or amazon prime
and watch it or get the blu-ray and
watch it in 3d and tell me what you
thought about it and that'll do it for
this movie retrospective i will see you
guys on the next one bye